[Musique]
c'était en 2007 à lumumbachi
ce regard cette voix
c'est dame à qui nous avions donné des
entrées
que la médecine doit être globale elle
me dit j'ai faim
mon rêve d'une santé meilleure en
Afrique
se confronte à cette réalité
de ses antirétroviraux son nutrition
mais tout commence ici à Abidjan
dans ce pays qui m'a vu naître qui m'a
vu grandir
autour de la tchéquée poisson avec mon
grand-père
à Marcory tous les dimanches où nous y
allions pour être en famille avec les
cousins les cousines les tentes et les
oncles
à parler de ces choses qu'il a vécu
de ce que son grand-père lui-même de ce
que son père lui-même mon grand-père lui
a inscrit cet amour pour la Côte
d'Ivoire c'est un mot pour ce pays qui a
tant donné à ses enfants
mais il y a aussi l'infirmière et le
médecin
qui
ont mis en moi ce désir d'une santé
meilleure pour tous
à 11 ans
en ce jour béni était le refrain
de la procession qui me menait pour ma
première communion
c'était le jour aussi où
la mort dans sa noblesse
emporter mon grand-père à sa dernière
demeure
et de lui
j'ai appris la foi
la foi
en ces choses qui sont assez
extraordinaire ce jour de cette première
communion dans l'allégresse dans la joie
mais en même temps dans la douleur de
cet enfant de 11 ans qui doit apprendre
à comprendre cette dualité entre la vie
et la mort
mais la vie continue
et il y a cette mère infirmière qui rêve
de la finance qui veut que son fils
devienne ce grand financier
mais le cœur va s'y rendre cette
question du développement dans le père
est tout au milieu inscrit dans cette
question de santé de développement de
ressources humaines et de ce que ce
monde doit devenir
j'ai pris le chemin intermédiaire
celui d'honorer la mémoire de ces deux
individus qui ont construit à la fois
une santé meilleure pour la Côte
d'Ivoire jusqu'à ce que ce dernier
décide de reprendre sa carrière pour une
santé meilleure pour l'Afrique et
peut-être le monde
alors
à 21 ans 20 ans je me retrouve au
Zimbabwe dans une ville où la plupart
des wests africains n'apparaissent pas
mais
j'apprends à ce côté ce que signifie
d'être un homme intègre
et cette intégrité
c'est quelque chose que je garde avec
moi
ou
ce jour de mes 23 ans
lui aussi comme mon grand-père parle
mais son rêve ne meurt pas parce que ce
jour-là je me dis
que je vais continuer la rue s'est
arrêté
ensuite il y a cette mère évidemment qui
veut que son fils devienne un financier
mais son fils a échoué à son cours de
finance trois fois
mission impossible
mais il faut honorer la mémoire de sa
mère
et à 37 ans
la noblesse de la mort vient frapper
et je commence cette carrière dans le
monde de la finance
elle est partie mais je continue ce
chemin quand elle a rêvé pour moi et
pour mes enfants
mais ses rêves n'ont de sens dans nos
vies
que si nous faisons tout pour que la
prochaine génération vive mieux
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
peut-être l'un des moments les plus
difficiles de la vie était ce moment où
en 2012 je deviens père
parce qu'à ce moment-là
c'est tout ce que mon grand-père mon
père ma mère mes arrières grands-pères
on transmis de génération en génération
cette volonté d'un monde meilleur pour
la prochaine génération
et à ce moment là je me suis dit
que je suis né
pour être responsable de la génération
de mes enfants
et que c'est de cette responsabilité que
naîtra cette volonté en moi de continuer
cette fois que mon grand-père m'a légué
de continuer cette intégrité que mon
père m'a légué
et aussi cette volonté de créer un monde
meilleur pour les autres
et d'être au service des autres
je pense très souvent à ce visage de
cette dame à Lubumbashi
et du chemin que j'ai parcouru
et ce que ma vie aurait été si je
n'avais pas rencontré si je n'avais pas
pensé
au fait que on a besoin de plus dans la
vie que ces éléments qui sont
ou qui ont l'air évident
alors
quand je pense
à ce qui m'a été légué
je pense que l'un des éléments
qui me revient le plus
c'est cette capacité à travailler pour
autrui et autrui pour moi aujourd'hui
signifie
que ma responsabilité est pour celle de
la prochaine génération
de génération en génération
nous devons penser
que ce qui est le plus important ce
n'est ni la vie ni la mort
mais c'est ce qui se passe entre les
deux
est-ce qu'il se passe entre les deux
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est d'être
présent dans la vie
de 11 ans et de 8 ans
pour que chaque jour il sache qu'ils
aient
ou ils ont eu dans leur vie un père
un grand-père un arrière-grand-père qui
a construit
qui a construit chaque jour
pour que les lendemains soient
différents
et aujourd'hui
présent dans cette salle
je pense à ce que chacun d'entre nous
ici a comme responsabilité
la responsabilité
de pouvoir faire pour autrui de manière
continuelle
ce que nous pensons souvent impossible
mon rêve pour la génération de mes
enfants
et ils puissent continuer à avoir la foi
la foi en la Côte d'Ivoire
la foi en Afrique
et la foi dans ce monde
le deuxième élément c'est l'intégrité
l'intégrité c'est peut-être l'une des
choses les plus simples à la fois les
plus difficiles
simple parce qu'on doit le pouvoir le
voir au quotidien difficile parce qu'il
va falloir le pratiquer
et la dernière chose pour moi
c'est de savoir comment
chaque jour le rêve que l'on nous
transmet doit se matérialiser de la
façon dont laquelle nous sommes capables
de le faire
ce n'est jamais parfait
et je ne sais pas si mes parents pensent
que ce que j'ai pu faire aujourd'hui est
parfait mais je sais que avec ce que
j'avais ce que j'avais reçu j'ai pu
avancer vers un chemin souvent nébuleux
souvent beau mais avec la conviction que
il n'y a que des lendemains qui sont
meilleurs
qu'on nous y croyons
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]